là où ça bouge contrôle de géographie on
va vous parler aujourd'hui de massif
central mais attention cet argent temps
vous me suivez
t'as voulu voir en soirée on a vu un bon
j'ai voulu voir environ la revue en bon
j'ai voulu barthassat on a vu ta mère
ils n'ont pas l'air de jouer mais le
spectacle est commencé d'ici là de quoi
en fait ça m'a glissé des mains et ch
était rien garrel j'ai apprécié ont
commencé à frapper ça donc pour
reprendre david oui donc ton histoire de
structures l'a souvent il n'ya pas une
histoire vraiment linéaire mais je
dirais simplement que c'est un groupe
d'individus qui débarque un petit peu
dans un espace sur un territoire
il était un petit peu en errance sur une
sorte de bateau de fortune
voilà une sorte de pirogues ou un radeau
et il percute une sorte de montagne et
sur ce territoire là ils se mettent à
bricoler à s'inventer des tas de choses
s'inventait des mondes un petit peu
comme des comme des enfants pourrait le
faire dans leur chambre ou dans le cadre
d'un atelier on a beaucoup comparé ce
plateau là un atelier et avec trois
bouts de bois trois fois rien quelques
outils un panneau
des tasseaux voilà il s'invente un monde
ils s'inventent des mondes des histoires
et
et voilà il joue en fait ils jouent ils
rêvent ensemble dans massif central le
travail des acteurs évoluent au fil des
situations jusqu'à une apothéose finale
étonnante et secrète
ça s'appelle massif central c'est demain
et après demain soir 20h30 au quai des
arts
ici argentan et je crois à mondeville au
mois de janvier on va leur prendre tout
début janvier à la renaissance à
mondeville le 8 janvier exactement à
20h30 je sais plus l'horaire exact
pardon on vous en reparlera dans là où
ça bouge bien sûr très bien
suite ils viennent de sortir leur
quatrième album lily wood and the prick
se rend à la luciole d'alençon demain
soir dépêchez vous il reste quelques
places et vendredi au cargö de caen
heureusement
à demain a évoqué
rada été